ähm liebe kollegen
liebe freunde
willkommen zu diesem ersten treffen des
diesjährigen leuvener seminars in klassischer
deutscher philosophie
heute hören wir zuerst einen vortrag von
jacques noller über khans und viktors
positionen in Bezug auf das handeln gegen
das
moralgesetz jorge knowler hat kürzlich die deutsche
habilitation bestanden  zum thema persönliche lebensformen,
identität, einheit und tugend
und jetzt privates zentrum an der
universität münchen
ist er autor einer beeindruckenden zahl
von veröffentlichten und bevorstehenden beiträgen,
herausgegebenen bänden und büchern,
von denen ich
einen beitrag erwähnt habe, der in einer europäischen zeitschrift
veröffentlicht wurde  Philosophy im Jahr 2019,
aber der Titel „practical reason is not a
will
cunt and reinhold’s dilemma
then äh“, ein zusammen mit
John Walsh herausgegebener Band über Waffen, frühe Kritiker
der Willensfreiheit,
ein Band, der
dieses Jahr bei Cambridge University
Press erscheinen wird,
sowie eine in Kürze erscheinende Monographie  mit
dem titel das schicksal der wahl freiheit und
verantwortung bei kant und seinen frühen
s  meine nachfolger
und ich erteilen jetzt york das wort, der
zusammen mit seinem gefängnis folien verwenden wird.
ja, vielen dank für die
einladung zu dieser
interessanten konferenz ich fühle mich sehr geehrt
, teil dieser konferenz zu sein, und mein
referat wird sich mit der frage beschäftigen, wie
Um die Vernunft zu verschleiern und wie Fiktionsfotze sich
vorstellte, gegen das moralische
Gesetz zu handeln
, hier ist der Überblick über meinen Vortrag. Zuerst
werde ich die Einführung geben, dann werde ich
darüber sprechen, was die
Leute Henry Elison Reinholds
Dilemma genannt hat. Sie haben einen Artikel
von mir
zu diesem Thema erwähnt  dann werde ich eine
exkursion über den verständlichen fatalismus von cal christian erharshmeed machen, der
für diese diskussion sehr wichtig ist,
dann werde ich übergehen zu
[ __ ] über die rationalisierung gegen das moralische
gesetz martin sticker hat kürzlich
ein interessantes buch zu diesem thema geschrieben, das
ich sehr hilfreich fand, werde ich  Diskutieren Sie das
ein wenig, dann werde ich
ungefähr 50 über die Verschleierung des moralischen Gesetzes durch Reflexion sprechen,
und am Ende wird es eine Schlussfolgerung geben
s  o kommen wir zum ersten
punkt, also die schlüsselfrage ist
die schlüsselfrage, die ich
zusammen mit [ __ ] und sieger erörtern werde, ist,
wie können wir gegen die forderung des
sittengesetzes vorgehen, damit
wir uns zunächst nicht absichtlich dagegen auflehnen
wäre ein
irrationales und sogar teuflisches
aber auch nicht wir sind nicht bloßen
naturkräften unterworfen das wäre nicht
zuzurechnen wir wären nur äh
von außen bestimmt das wäre überhaupt nichts
autonomes
anders sagen wie können wir das erst
rational und  zweitens zurechnungsfähig handeln
gegen die forderung des sittengesetzes also
das ist die schlüsselfrage
reden wir über reinholds dilemma also gibt
es erstens widersprüchlichkeitsthese
sie alle kennen das aus seiner religion
er sagt der mensch muss
sich zu was auch immer machen oder gemacht haben  er ist oder
sollte im moralischen Sinne gut oder
böse werden, diese beiden Charaktere müssen sich als
Wirkung seiner freien Entscheidungsgewalt
heilsam fühlen, denn sonst könnten sie ihm nicht
zugerechnet werden  ihm und folglich
könnte er weder moralisch gut noch böse sein, dass
dies seine Zurechenbarkeitsthese sei,
und mehr Zurechenbarkeit ist laut
[ __ ] unvereinbar mit erster äußerer
Bestimmung des Willens oder Heteronomie
und auch keiner Bestimmung von allem, was
wir Indifferentismus nennen können,
also ist hier Khans Autonomie  Frage
nämlich, ob die reine Vernunft oder
allein ausreicht, um den Willen zu bestimmen, oder
ob er nur empirisch bedingt eine bestimmende Krone
des Willens sein kann
und gehen wir zu Khans
Autonomiethese über, er argumentiert, dass der freie Wille
nicht gesetzlos ist, also gibt es keinen
Indifferentismus, der mit der Autonomie verbunden ist, aber
der Wille muss stattdessen eine Kausalität
nach unveränderlichen Gesetzen sein,
aber einer besonderen Art,
denn sonst wäre ein freier Wille ein
Unding,
also ist hier die Frage, welche Art von Gesetz
wir uns vorstellen,
um die Autonomie zu haben  des Willens Ein
weiteres Zitat, das in
diesem Zusammenhang entscheidend ist, ist, dass der freie Wille
nach Khan eine Art Kausalität ist  von lebenden
wesen und soweit sie rational sind
und freiheit wäre die eigenschaft einer
solchen kausalität, dass sie
unabhängig von fremden
ursachen wirksam sein kann, die sie bestimmen, also ist sie gegen heteronomie, autonomie und schließlich dieses sehr berühmte zitieren khans reziprozitätsthese, wie alison es
formuliert hat  Zitat: Ein freier Wille und ein Wille
unter moralischen Gesetzen sind ein und dasselbe,
also ist dies die Grundlage seiner Konzeption
von Autonomie
und aus dieser Autonomiethese
geht hervor, was
ähm und Hudson Khans
Autonomieproblem oder Cons-Eindringbarkeitsproblem genannt haben
, nämlich es gibt erste Dosen
Zurechenbarkeitsthese die freie handelnde Person ist
moralisch verantwortlich für ihr moralisch
richtiges und falsches Handeln und hat die freie
Wahl zwischen den Alternativen Gut
und Böse
und Khans Autonomiethese, dass die
absolute Ursache des autonomen Handelns
in der Kausalität der reinen praktischen
Vernunft und ihrem moralischen
Gesetz liegt  daraus
ergibt sich, was henry ellison
das dilemma von reinhold und michelle kosh
reinh genannt hat  die beschwerde des alten
und hier ein langes zitat von
carlyon weinhold
aus seinem
zweiten band seiner briefe zur
kentuckianischen philosophie das ist meine
übersetzung
wenn der wille nur in bezug
auf moralisches handeln frei wäre und der grund
unmoralischen handelns außerhalb des willens in
äußeren hindernissen gelegt wäre  und Schranken, so wäre auch
der Grund moralischen Handelns
keineswegs in der bloßen
Selbsttätigkeit der praktischen Vernunft zu finden,
sondern ohne diese
von dieser Vernunft ganz unabhängigen Hindernisse
die ganze Freiheit dieser Vernunft
und durch sie auch  der Person
nur in einer zufälligen Unabhängigkeit
von äußerer Gewalt bestünde, und beschränkt auf
bestimmte Fälle, die keineswegs
in der Macht der Person stünden, würde die moralische
Handlung unweigerlich durch eine
ganz unfreiwillige
Unwillkürlichkeit praktischer Vernunft folgen, sobald dies der Fall
wäre  kein
Hindernis sein und die moralische oder unmoralische Handlung
müsste der bloßen
Anwesenheit oder Abwesenheit dieses obs zugeschrieben werden  Das
ist also eine sehr
faszinierende, interessante Kritik von
Reinhold, und
sagen wir es als Reinholds Herausforderung. Es muss eine
Konzeption des freien Willens
entwickelt werden, die zunächst einen verständlichen Fatalismus vermeidet
drei
punkte, die wir berücksichtigen
müssen, um eine konzeption von freiheit zu entwickeln,
die volle moralische eingabefähigkeit in
Bezug auf unmoralische
handlungen zulässt henry citric argumentierte in seiner berühmten arbeit über die kentsche
konzeption eines freien willens von 1888
, dass cunt entweder ausdrücklich oder
implizit identifiziere willen  und der Grund
für diese Identifizierung offensichtlich
die Möglichkeit des Willens ausschließt
, zwischen Vernunft und nicht-rationalen Impulsen zu wählen,
fährt er fort, indem er argumentiert, dass
es eine Verwechslung zu geben scheint zwischen zuerst der Freiheit
, die sich nur in rechtem Verhalten verwirklicht,
wenn die Vernunft
Verführungen des Appetits oder der Leidenschaft erfolgreich widersteht  und
zweitens die Freiheit, zwischen
Recht und Unrecht zu wählen  ng was natürlich
in beiden entscheidungen gleichermaßen verwirklicht wird
kommen wir zu ii ich möchte jetzt äh
schmidts verständlichen fatalismus erörtern und
bevor ich
über schmidt spreche, möchte
ich die aufmerksamkeit auf johann august
heinrich wury lenken, der
in der philosophischen debatte aber fast völlig unbekannt ist
in seiner Wahllehre von 1788
gestrichene Frage zitieren, ob diese
Fähigkeit der praktischen Vernunft
auch unabhängig von allen anderen Gründen angewandt wird
oder nicht, also unabhängig von
solchen Gründen, die nicht zeitweilig nicht vernünftige
Anreize oder nicht bloße Scheinerscheinungen waren,
also was die
bestimmenden Gründe sind
vernunft der reinen praktischen vernunft
nach uri sind unmoralische handlungen die
folgen einer
schwäche des intelligiblen charakters,
so ist dies seiner konzeption nach eine art
private entbehrungstheorie
und nennt christian er schmidt in seinem
versuch einer moralphilosophie von 1790
92 sogar  mehr
Versionen seines Versuchs ähm
viele viele aber ich denke das sind die
ersten a  nd wichtigstens
versuchte Christian Eric Schmidt
, die Schwäche, auf die
Willy hinwies, des intelligiblen
Charakters in Bezug auf intelligible und
nicht empirische, aber intelligible Hindernisse
für die praktische Vernunft zu erklären, ein Zitat, wenn und
insofern Handeln den Eindruck
rationaler Selbsttätigkeit trägt oder  wenn eine gegebene
substanz
nach der form der vernunft bestimmt und behandelt wird, dann sind
sie sittliche handlungen,
demgegenüber sind sie insofern unmoralisch, als von
einer wirkung der selbsttätigen
vernunft keine spur kommt
dieselbe moral offenbart sich in allen
wahrnehmbaren handlungen, also warum handeln wir nicht
immer moralisch, sondern manchmal
unmoralisch
und noch ein zitieren eine andere frage
, inwiefern kann die vernunft als
bedingung der unvernunft bezeichnet werden, also ist dies die
frage meines gesamten referats,
also aus diesem grund schmidt  ist sehr
wichtig für diese diskussion
und in seinem versuch einer moralphilosophie
argumentierte schmidt schließlich für a  entbehrungstheorie
unmoralischer handlungen
es gibt nun einige zitate, die
für dieses thema sehr entscheidend sind erstens
unmoralische handlungen und einstellungen
hängen keineswegs von der eigenen absoluten selbsttätigkeit ab
,
sondern vielmehr von der entbehrung derselben ein
weiteres zitat ist die fähigkeit zu unmoralischem handeln,
wie schmidt sagt  Es ist eine
Folge der Einschränkung unserer
Freiheit, die im Hinblick auf die Begründung
ihrer Unfähigkeit
Unfähigkeit ein sehr interessanter Begriff ist,
sicherlich auch im Hinblick auf die [ __ ] eines
anderen Zitats
fähigkeit zur moralischen freiheit ein
anderes zitat wir haben keine freiheit kein
innerer ursprünglicher innerer bestimmender grund
das böse zu wollen sondern sind insofern
lediglich abhängig
schließlich die fähigkeit unsittlich zu handeln ist
also ein undenkbarer
gedanke eine nichtgedankennische die hier aus samt ein gelehrter auf schmidt
hat
Ich denke, ich habe die Bedeutung von Schmidts Konzept der Unfähigkeit hervorgehoben, wenn es um Khans Metaphysik der Moral geht
Dies ist eine interessante Referenz, die
ausführlicher entwickelt werden muss,
aber nicht in diesem Vortrag. Lassen Sie uns mit der
Rationalisierung gegen das moralische Gesetz fortfahren.
Wenn also der freie Wille und reine praktische
Gründe als Grund
identifiziert werden müssen, wie Kant argumentiert, dann
scheint dies der Fall zu sein  keinen Raum für sittenwidrige Handlungen haben
, die unserer individuellen
Freiheit zuzurechnen sind, stellt sich die Frage, ob
sittenwidrige Handlungen
als privativ und irrational zu charakterisieren sind
oder ob unsere
Schuldzuweisung eher auf der Annahme beruht, dass
die jeweilige Handlung stattgefunden hat  Aus
bestimmten Gründen, die dem freien Agenten zuzuschreiben sind,
kommen wir zu einem anderen Punkt, den
ich als das sokratische Paradoxon beschrieben habe,
weil Khans Moralphilosophie
durch dieses Paradoxon in Frage gestellt wird
der Entbehrungsthese
bei unsittlichen Handlungen scheinen
wir unsere Vernunft nicht zu Recht zu
unterwerfen  einem irrtum zu unterwerfen und daher
irrational oder
unabsichtlich unmoralisch zu
handeln hat donald davidson diese
position als das plato-prinzip bezeichnet. ein zitieren
von davidson nach platon sokrates
argumentierte, dass da niemand freiwillig
gegen das handelt, was er am besten
nur aus unwissenheit kann  törichte oder böse Taten erklären,
solche Handlungen werden durch die
Logik der Begriffe ausgeschlossen, keine absichtliche
Handlung kann innerlich irrational sein
und hier ist die Rationalitätsthese, dass
wir für unsere unmoralischen Handlungen verantwortlich sind,
solange sie aus freien Stücken geschehen,
sodass wir sie verfolgen müssen  zurück zu einer
bestimmten form von reflexivität und
rationalität
michelle koch hat dieses dilemma in einem kürzlich erschienenen beitrag
anders,
aber dennoch ähnlich formuliert:
erstens ist die rationalität einer
handlung eine notwendige bedingung der
freiheit dieser handlung und zweitens die
rationalität  einer Handlung ist eine hinreichende
Bedingung für die moralische Güte dieser
Handlungsfotze, die
versucht, dem sokratischen Para zu entkommen
dox durch die entwicklung einer ausgeklügelten
theorie der moralischen selbsttäuschung, wodurch
sowohl die forderung des entbehrungsmitleids
als auch die forderung der rationalität befriedigt werden,
und hier ist khans konzept der
rationalisierung, zu dem martin sticker
ein interessantes buch geschrieben hat, und dieses
konzept, so wie ich es interpretiere, öffnet einen weg
diesem paradoxon zu entkommen, das
als ausweg aus einholds
dilemma zwischen verständlichem fatalismus
und indifferentismus gegenüber
unmoralischem handeln interpretiert werden kann,
[ __ ] liefert in seiner konzeption der rationalisierung
eine implizite es ist keine
explizite und implizite lösung des
zurechenbarkeitsproblems es ist keine
sensibilität  treibt uns zur
Unmoral als eine Art Heteronomie noch
Vernunft im Sinne einer Unfähigkeit, sondern
Vernunft insofern, als sie dialektisch ist
für eine allgemeine Diskussion von Khans
Konzeption der Harz-
Rationalisierungsfunktion siehe Aufkleber 2021, jedoch nicht
im Hinblick auf Reinholds Dilemma und
Widerlegbarkeitsproblem in in  Als spezielle
Diskussion ist es ein sehr sehr gutes ähm
vorbei  Ansicht, aber nicht, es geht nicht
genau um dieses Thema, sonst
müsste ich diesen Vortrag heute nicht halten.
Ähm, okay, aber ich empfehle dieses
Buch wirklich
Wir können
aus Gründen
, die uns als freien Handelnden
zuzurechnen sind, gegen die Forderungen des Sittengesetzes vorgehen und eröffnen einen Ausweg aus dem sokratischen
Paradoxon
und argumentieren damit gegen die Ansicht, dass Irrtum
nur auf eine
Einschränkung unserer rationalen Leistungsfähigkeit zurückzuführen ist  das problem
von reinhardts dilemma
ist in einem größeren zusammenhang die
zurechenbarkeit von fehlern als solchen, damit wir
zwischen theoretischen fehlern
und praktischen fehlern unterscheiden können
hier mal ein zitat gegen die
entbehrungstheorie des
fehlercodes in den einschränkungen des
verständnisses liegt nur die
schuld an der unwissenheit  eine
Verantwortung für Fehler, die wir
uns selbst zuschreiben müssen
wir irren gemäß kann nicht nie
absichtlich, sondern immer
im Modus von s  selbstverursachte Illusion, so
dass das Subjektzitat die
Illusion der Wahrheit mit der Wahrheit selbst verwechselt,
aber hier stellt sich die Frage, wie
wir dann einen Irrtum, sei er
theoretisch oder praktisch, so verstehen können,
dass er nicht zunächst nur
ein auf Fremdbestimmung zurückzuführendes Versehen ist
Begrenzungsumständen
, die eine Art Fatalismus oder
Determinismus oder vielleicht auch Entbehrungstheorie wären,
und auch nicht so, dass wir
wissentlich und willentlich den Irrtum begehen, der
eine Form des Irrationalismus wäre, den
Sie im Sinne des moralisch Bösen
teuflisch kennen
also wie können wir aus Gründen handeln, die
uns zuzurechnen sind und welche
Gründe wir haben sollten, uns selbst zu betrügen und zu belügen,
ist kein Selbstbetrug oder Irrtum, ein bloßer
Irrtum, der aus Mangel an Vernunft und
Unfähigkeit besteht
, mit ihm zu sprechen
schmidt donald davidson hat darauf hingewiesen, dass das zitat die möglichkeit
von irrationalität
in hohem maße von rationalität abhängt
irrationalität ist nicht einfach zitieren mangel
an vernunft  aber zitieren Sie eine Störung der
Vernunft und kann daher nicht
nur privat verstanden werden, also denke ich, es geht
darum, wie man eine
Störung der Vernunft versteht. Was stört die Vernunft, ist es
etwas Äußeres oder ist es vielleicht
die freie und verantwortliche Person,
also spricht Davidson über Störung
In diesem Zusammenhang von Zitat das
Paradoxon der Irrationalität Zitat die
Idee einer irrationalen Handlung Überzeugung Absicht
Einmischung oder Emotion ist paradox,
denn das Irrationale ist nicht nur das
Nicht-Rationale, das außerhalb des
Bereichs des Rationalen liegt Irrationalität ist ein
Versagen innerhalb des Hauses der Vernunft  ich
finde diese metapher ziemlich interessant,
weil sie etwas mit vernunft zu tun hat,
aber wir müssen
die beziehung zwischen
irrationalität und dem haus der vernunft wirklich definieren,
wie lebt die
irrationalität im haus der
vernunft, das ist die frage, die kant
und auch victor versuchen  Die Diskussion
irrationaler Handlungen kann
aus der Gründe-Perspektive verständlicher gemacht werden
der agent, den davidson
interessanterweise rationalisierend rationalisieren nennt,
besteht
laut davidson darin, dass
die gründe für das verstehen einer
irrationalen handlung eine
zitierende aura der rationalität mit sich tragen, dh dass sie
immer rechtfertigung beanspruchen, wer also rechtfertigung beansprucht,
begründet das, was
er oder sie hat  getan
und die gründe haben mit rationalität zu tun
davidson betont die bedeutung von
gründen für irrationalität ein weiteres
zitat irrationalität erscheint nur dann,
wenn rationalität offensichtlich
angemessen ist, wenn sowohl ursache als auch
wirkung inhalte haben, die die art von
logischen beziehungen haben, die aus grund
oder seinem versagen ereignisse machen  allein
in Bezug auf ihre physikalischen oder
physiologischen Eigenschaften, die der
Heteronomie zufolge nicht
als Gründe oder als Konflikte beurteilt werden können
oder sich mit einem Gegenstand befassen,
muss sie in einer Beziehung
zur Vernunft stehen,
wie Davidson es ausdrückt, bloße natürliche Ursachen
oder blind  Kräfte sind in der Kategorie von
t  er nicht-rational, nicht das irrationale, also
finde ich diese unterscheidung zwischen dem
nicht-rationalen und dem irrationalen sehr
entscheidend für diese diskussion
wie davidson oder vielleicht besser davidson
wie [ __ ] [ __ ] versteht fehler als
zuschreibbar und bis jetzt werden sie
diesen grund verwenden, um einen zu konstruieren  illusorisch, aber
dennoch rational ordnung
rational auf diese weise bedeutet, dass es
gründe gibt sinnlichkeit allein kann nicht
fehlerquelle sein, weil es laut
khan keine propositionsstruktur hat hier ist ein
sehr berühmtes zitieren neigung ist
blind und diener ob freundlich
oder nicht und  Wenn die Moral in Frage steht,
darf die Vernunft nicht die Rolle des bloßen
Wächters der Neigung spielen, sondern
muss sich, wenn sie sie insgesamt missachtet, ausschließlich ihrem
eigenen Interesse als reiner praktischer Vernunft widmen, so dass die
Neigung ein blinder Diener ist, was bedeutet,
dass keine Rationalität involviert ist, keine
Gründe in die Neigung involviert sind,
daher muss der Fehler sein  haben ihren Ursprung in der
Beziehung zwischen Sinnlichkeit und
Vernunft  ihr Zitat aus der
Yeshi-Logik
der Grund für die Entstehung aller Irrtümer
wird also
schlicht und allein in dem unbemerkten
Einfluß der Sinnlichkeit auf den
Verstand zu suchen sein, oder genauer gesagt
auf das Urteil
bewirkt dieser Einfluß nämlich
das im Urteil wir  bloß
subjektive gründe für objektiv zu halten und
folglich die bloße illusion
der wahrheit mit der wahrheit selbst zu verwechseln finde ich
den begriff verwirrung sehr wichtig im sinne
von gründen für sittenwidriges handeln, was
gerade in diesem sinne darin besteht, dass das wesen der
illusion darin besteht,
was deswegen
ist  als grund für
die wahrheit einer falschen erkenntnis angesehen zu werden,
was den irrtum ermöglicht, ist dann
illusion, wonach das
bloß subjektiv im
urteil mit dem objektiven verwechselt wird auch der
urteilsbegriff ist
in diesem zusammenhang von
großer bedeutung kant argumentiert, dass a  praktischer Irrtum ist
kein rein privates Phänomen, sondern eine
spezifische Form frei zurechenbarer
Tätigkeit  Die empirische Verfassung des Menschen kann
keinen Grund für die Freiheit des Bösen liefern,
weil sie nur Tatsachen über seinen
natürlichen Haarzustand durch
Wünsche und Neigungen liefert, aber die Wurzel des
Bösen kann nicht in der Vernunft selbst liegen, weder
eine vom Sittengesetz entlastete noch
eine böse Vernunft zitieren  ein
absolut böser Wille würde
dagegen gleichsam zuviel enthalten, weil der
Widerstand gegen das Gesetz dadurch selbst zum Antrieb
erhoben würde, denn
ohne jeden Antrieb ist die
Entscheidungsgewalt nicht bestimmbar und so
würde hier das Subjekt zu einem teuflischen Wesen gemacht
Die Frage ist, wie können wir uns
das Verhältnis zwischen unserem
Willen, unserer Vernunft und dem moralischen Gesetz so vorstellen, dass
es weder eine bloße
Entbehrung
im Sinne unmoralischer Handlungen noch
etwas teuflisches ist,
das einer direkten Rebellion
gegen die
Vernunft gleicht,
so dass die Frage aufgeworfen wurde, wie
um die Gründe für unmoralisches Handeln zu verstehen
Khans Konzept der Rationalisierung,
das eine Antwort auf die Fragen liefert  die erkenntnis,
wie böse handlungen aus zurechenbaren gründen begangen werden können, die
eine ordnung der illusion darstellen, ist
in dieser art in seiner anthropologie sehr wichtig. aus
pragmatischer sicht definiert khan
rationalisieren als code einen vernunftgebrauch
, der teils aus unfähigkeit, teils sein endgültiges ziel verfehlt
aus einer inopera
unangemessenen sichtweise finde ich das unvermögen
nicht so
gut gewählt sondern eher
diese unangemessene sichtweise so
nehmen wir haltung zum moralgesetz
kant fügt dann direkt die folgende
definition zu toben mit vernunft rasiert
mittel nach prinzipien vorzugehen
in form von  sein gedanke aber im
stoff oder zweck mittel zu verwenden, die ihm
direkt entgegenstehen
kants unterscheidung zwischen form und
stoff kann folgendermaßen verstanden
werden, indem rationalisierend ein formaler zusammenhang
von maximen erzeugt wird, der
jedoch nur die illusion von
moral und konformität suggeriert  das moralische Gesetz
folgt aber in Wirklichkeit materiellen und
individuellen Motiven
aus einer praktischen Po
Rationalisierung besteht aus der Sichtweise darin,
Gründe gegen die absolute
Forderung des Sittengesetzes vorzubringen und
damit eine eigene moralische Ordnung zu konstruieren,
innerhalb derer das eigene Handeln
schließlich als gut erscheint, also die Haltung
, die man gegenüber dem Sittengesetz einnimmt, dessen
Störung
das Handeln ist
sozusagen störung im sinne von davidson in der grundlage
der metaphysischen moral und martin
sticker hat dies ausführlicher erörtert
khan spricht von einem mächtigen
gegengewicht zu allen kommentaren der
pflicht, die der mensch in sich empfindet reine
praktische vernunft durch ihre universelle und
kategorische  Gebot setzt
individuelle Bedürfnisse zurück und Zitat
ergibt sich aus diesem Gegensatz eine natürliche Dialektik,
die Khan als
Rationalisierungsneigung
gegenüber diesen strengen Pflichtgesetzen definiert,
diese Neigung selbst trägt jedoch
rationale Züge, sie ist
wie bei der theoretischen
Dialektik Dialektik eine Form  aus
perverser Vernunft und ich werde
jetzt dieses Konzept diskutieren  ion der
verdunkelung des sittengesetzes
vor dem hintergrund von khans
konzeption von rationalize
so gibt es vier problemstellungen der
individuellen willensselbstbestimmung
, die nach kant und
einhold fixiert werden, um der
skepsis an der willensfreiheit angesichts des
dilemmas zu entgehen  des Indifferentismus und des
verständlichen Fatalismus
, hier also die vier
Punkte, für die er argumentiert: Erstens muss die
moralisch verantwortliche Person
als ein einheitliches, sowohl rationales als auch vernünftiges
Individuum konzipiert werden, zweitens muss der freie Wille
von der allgemeinen Fähigkeit
der reinen praktischen Vernunft unterschieden werden, um dies zu tun
Um die Gefahr eines nachvollziehbaren
Fatalismus zu vermeiden und eine Vorstellung von
individueller Selbstbestimmung zu entwickeln, muss
jedoch eine spezifische Form der Rationalität
und Reflexivität der Herrschaft
gewahrt und analysiert werden, um
die Gefahr des Indifferentismus oder
empirischen Determinismus zu vermeiden und schließlich
moralisch falsch handeln zu müssen  als
etwas Zugeschriebenes verstanden  fähig
im Lichte des Moralgesetzes, also nicht
direkt gegen das Moralgesetz, aber immer noch
im Einklang mit dem Moralgesetz, also muss es immer
noch eine Beziehung
zum Moralgesetz geben, aber eine verworrene
Beziehung.
Ich werde diese Verwirrung oder
Störung der diskutieren  Beziehung zum moralischen Gesetz,
das unserer individuellen
Freiheit zuzuschreiben ist, aber zuerst
die sehr frühe 50 in seiner
Rezension von 1793 über Leonard Cohens skeptische
Reflexionen über die Freiheit des Willens
in dieser Rezension 50 würdigte
Reinhold für den Hinweis auf das Problem von
verständlich gewordener Fatalismus, der
gewalttätig wird und wenn Wille und reine
praktische Vernunft
eng zu identifizieren sind, so ist dies
der Punkt, nicht die Beziehung
dieser
beiden
Fähigkeiten, sondern die strikte Identität,
die problematisch ist, es geht um die
Beziehung, wie man sie sich vorstellt  Diese
Beziehung
also hier ist ein Zitat, das eine Reihe von
Befürwortern der kritischen Philosophie bemerkt haben
und das Reinhold deutlich gemacht hat  gezeigt,
dass wir sorgfältig unterscheiden müssen
zwischen jener Manifestation absoluter
Selbsttätigkeit, wodurch die Vernunft
praktisch ist und sich selbst ein Gesetz gibt, und
jener Manifestation absoluter
Selbsttätigkeit, wobei der Mensch in
dieser Funktion seinen Willen bestimmt
, diesem Gesetz zu gehorchen oder nicht
Sieger zu sein  mit reinhold in
der kritik schmidts verständlichen
fatalismus und stellt fest, dass die kodifizierung von
schuld und verdienst in dieser theorie aufhört, die
auf [ __ ] 50 in seinem
ethiksystem zurückgreift, argumentiert, dass es absolut
unmöglich und widersprüchlich ist, dass jeder
mit einem klaren bewusstsein seiner pflicht
in dem moment er
Taten guten Gewissens beschließen könnten, seine Pflicht nicht zu tun
, dass er sich gegen das Gesetz auflehnen sollte, ihm
den Gehorsam verweigern und
es zu seiner Maxime machen, seine Pflicht nicht zu tun, weil
es seine Pflicht ist,
so dass diese Art einer engen Beziehung
zum moralischen Gesetz unmöglich ist  für
50 wie für schnitt, aber das heißt nicht,
dass es kein komplexeres
Verhältnis zum moralischen l geben kann  aw, das
es uns erlaubt, dagegen
vorzugehen, obwohl es nach ficht rational ist, dass es konzeptionell
unmöglich ist, dass eine Person gegen
die Normativität der Moral durch die
Fähigkeit handelt, die sie direkt garantiert,
nämlich praktische Vernunft,
Zitat in einem im selben Moment,
daher wären diese widersprüchlichen Forderungen
ihm von einem in
gleicher kraft eine voraussetzung auferlegt, die sich
selbst einträgt und den klarsten und geduldigsten widerspruch mit sich bringt.
ich habe das bereits besprochen,
also hier noch ein punkt, so etwas wie
ein böser grund ist metaphysisch
unmöglich, ein grund
, der am  gleichzeitig das
Gute befiehlt und den
direkt motivierenden Grund für das Handeln
gegen sein Gebot in sich aufhebt
, würde sich selbst aufheben, so dass dies sicherlich ein
Widerspruch wäre,
aber wie kann das Böse
als ein freies Handeln erklärt werden, wenn man es wie
Khan nicht tut  auf die Sensibilität zurückführen wollen,
wie wir uns ein Individuum vorstellen können
Rationalität, die nicht mit
der universellen Rationalität des
Sittengesetzes identisch ist und die der Grund für die
Zurechenbarkeit des begangenen Bösen ist
, um die Zurechenbarkeit böser Handlungen zu rechtfertigen,
50 führt den Begriff
der Reflexion ein, dem
dieser Begriff dient, um
das Problem zu vermeiden  verständlicher Fatalismus
bei bösen Taten, weil er
uns begreifen lässt, wie wir zwar frei und
zurechenbar gegen die Forderung des
Sittengesetzes handeln können,
aber nicht direkt und unmittelbar,
was ein begrifflicher
Widerspruch wäre oder anders gesagt, eine
teuflische Tat 50 , der nicht zugestimmt wird  diese
direkte gegensätzlichkeit ist eine kompliziertere
und fiktive argumentation geht so
erstens wenn man ständig über
die forderung des rechts nachdenkt steht diese forderung einem
immer vor augen dann ist
es unmöglich nicht
nach dieser forderung zu handeln oder sich ihr zweitens zu widersetzen
wenn das Gesetz jedoch aus unserer Aufmerksamkeit verschwindet,
dann ist es für uns unmöglich,
rechtskräftig zu handeln  Entsprechend
herrscht also in beiden Fällen die Notwendigkeit,
und wir scheinen uns in
eine Art verständlichen Fatalismus
verfangen zu haben, dieser Art
verständlicher Fatalismus ist
im Sinne von Schmidts Bericht nicht zu verstehen,
weil er in einem etwas geringeren
Maße als zitiert ist  Der übliche
schwache verständliche Fatalismus,
ich nenne ihn schwach,
unterscheidet sich vom starken verständlichen
Fatalismus, der der allgemeine
intellektuelle Fatalismus ist, weil er
nur unsere erkenntnistheoretische
Beziehung zum normativen Inhalt
des Moralgesetzes betrifft, aber nicht eine starke
motivationale Beziehung zu seinem
Anreiz, wodurch die  moralisches Gesetz wird
wirksam ohne Beteiligung
des moralischen Subjekts
Victor argumentiert, dass starker intelligibler
Fatalismus allein dadurch vermieden werden kann,
dass es konzeptionell unmöglich ist, dass
das moralische Gesetz nicht
ohne unser Bewusstsein und unsere
Reflexion davon, die jedoch nicht unabhängig
von uns ist, praktisch werden kann  sondern hängt von unserem Willen
Victor t ab  spricht daher von einem bloßen
Anschein von Fatalismus, dessen Code
verschwindet, sobald man merkt, dass
es an unserer Freiheit liegt, ob ein solches
Bewusstsein fortbesteht oder
verdunkelt wird, also ist dies der eigentliche
Begriff der Verantwortung
für unmoralisches Handeln, es geht also um
den willentlichen
Gebrauch des
Bewusstseins  eine Art der
Darstellung des Moralischen daher können wir
den verständlichen Fatalismus nur vermeiden, wenn
Reflexion und Darstellung der
Forderung des Sittengesetzes, nicht aber dessen
Inhalt
von uns abhängen,
können wir
das Sittengesetz nach 50 durch unsere
Reflexionsfähigkeit seit der Reflexion willentlich ausblenden  ist nichts
bloß Theoretisches, sondern
Praktisches und Wollenswertes,
daher unterliegen wir im unmoralischen Handeln nicht
einer Willensschwäche
wie Schmidt und Willie in ihrer
Vorstellung einer Art verständlichen
Fatalismus oder Irrationalität, sondern sind
verantwortlich für die Art und Weise, wie wir
reflektieren  auf die absolute Forderung des
Sittengesetzes, so obliegt es
der Reflexion reflecti  on is also it’s a
activity that we are responsible for
triumph argumentiert, dass der Grund für unsere
Verschleierung der Forderung des moralischen Gesetzes
unsere Aktivität der Abstraktion ist, die zu dem
führt, was wir unbestimmtes
Denken nennen, und ein Zitat von Gedankenlosigkeit und
Unaufmerksamkeit gegenüber unserer höheren
Natur  bedeutet nicht, dass wir überhaupt
kein bewusstsein für die moral der
forderung des moralgesetzes haben,
sondern unbestimmtes pflichtdenken
bedeutet, das moralgesetz auf einer zweiten ebene zu verletzen,
da ein bestimmtes
pflichtbewusstsein selbst eine pflicht ist,
wie viktor es ausdrückt
bei bösen handlungen ist unsere
determinante das bewusstsein des
sittengesetzes und das ist wichtig, es wird nicht
sofort, sondern sukzessive in einen zustand verwandelt, den
der sieg
ein unbestimmtes und schwankendes
bewusstsein nennt
victor erklärt den komplexen prozess
der bestimmung und verdunkelung des
sittengesetzes  sich auf die menschliche
Vorstellungskraft zu
berufen, um zu einer bestimmten
Repräsentation zu gelangen  Unsere Vorstellungskraft
muss von unserem Verstand beherrscht werden
, der
ihr zitierscharfe Umrisse gibt, wie Fichte es ausdrückt,
aber da unsere
Vorstellungskraft die Neigung hat, im Verzicht zwischen Gegensätzen zu schweben,
laufen diese scharfen Umrisse Gefahr, wieder zu
verschwimmen  ein Sonderfall des
Bestimmtheitsverlustes, der mit dem
Problem des Handelns gegen die Forderung
des Sittengesetzes in Verbindung gebracht werden kann und das er als
Zitatergebnis von Zerstreutheit und
Gedankenlosigkeit bezeichnet, in der
Regel ist unser Verstand nicht stark
genug, um die Bestimmtheit des
Gegenstandes unseres zu fixieren  Bedenkt man, dass die Forderung des
moralischen Gesetzes eingeschlossen ist, so dass ihre
Bestimmung
entgeht, wenn der Sieg es zu einem so
unbestimmten Objekt macht, wie 50
argumentiert, und unsere Urteilskraft es nicht
fixieren kann
, können wir jetzt nur drei
verschiedene Arten unterscheiden, die
Stärke des moralischen Gesetzes zu umgehen, das es ist  es geht nicht darum zu
rebellieren, es geht darum, das
moralische Gesetz zu umgehen, das ist der entscheidende Teil von
Victor First Wi  th Hinweis auf die Forderung
des Sittengesetzes Fikte weist auf eine Art
Verdunkelung unseres moralischen Gewissens
hin, die uns zu einer
Art moralischen Selbsttäuschung führt Victor
betont, dass diese
Selbsttäuschung nicht nichts ist, sondern
nur etwas  wie von äußeren Einflüssen mit uns geschieht,
sondern
etwas, das
unserer Willenstätigkeit zuzurechnen ist, da die
Bestimmtheit und das Vorhandensein der
Forderung des Sittengesetzes von unserer
individuellen Freiheit abhängen, also das Vorhandensein
dieser Forderung von uns nicht dem
Inhalt, sondern dem abhängt  Art und Weise, wie
er uns erscheint,
50 zeichnet eine andere Art von
Bestimmung des Sittengesetzes aus, die wir
bei unmoralischem Handeln durch Reflexion verdunkeln,
es geht um die Strenge und unmittelbare
Geltung des Sittengesetzes, seinen
kategorischen Imperativ,
diesen Imperativ können wir durch eine Tätigkeit verdunkeln  was
victor verzögern nennt,
beim verzögern der forderung des moralischen gesetzes sind
wir in eine ähnliche tätigkeit
verstrickt wie kant rationala genannt hat
Die moralische Forderung zu verzögern bedeutet nicht,
sie einfach zu ignorieren, sondern
zu begründen, so dass man
durch Ausnahmen berechtigt erscheint, ihr nicht
sofort und anonym zu folgen
, also nicht, dass wir uns gegen das Mehrgesetz auflehnen,
aber das  wir haben Gründe
für eine Entschuldigung für Hinrichtungen
schließlich 50 unterscheidet eine Art
Verschleierung des moralischen Gesetzes, die darin besteht,
den formalen und a priori
kategorischen Imperativ zu etwas
Empirischem und Bedingtem wie einem bloßen
Zitat herabzustufen
Die absolute Forderung des Sittengesetzes,
die unsere Neigung zur Selbstüberheblichkeit nicht als
Sieger bezeichnet hat, argumentiert, dass diese Art von
Einwänden während des Sittengesetzes eine
besondere Gefahr für die menschliche Existenz
darstellt und natürlich
zu einer Radikalisierung führen wird  und perversion
des moralischen gesetzes
nach victor der eigentliche grund für die
verschleierung der forderung des moralischen gesetzes
besteht in einem zitat ursprüngliche faulheit o  Die
Trägheit tracheid in Bezug auf die
Reflexion, die im
Folgenden Khan zitiert, ist ein wirklich
positives radikales Übel, das
von einem einfach negativen zu unterscheiden ist.
Hier stellt sich also die Frage, wie wir
Trägheit verstehen sollen, ist sie nur ein
privatives Phänomen wie Schmidt in seinem
verständlichen Fatalismus oder  können wir
die Trägheit als eine
unserer individuellen
Freiheit
zuzuschreibende Handlungsweise interpretieren 50
diese Trägheit der Reflexion sollte nicht
im Sinne einer privativen Theorie gedacht werden,
da dies letztlich auf einen
verständlichen Fatalismus hinauslaufen würde
50 daher weiter charakterisiert
und in  die systematische nähe zu leibniz
hat diese trägheit als kraft
der kraft bezeichnet, die ausreicht,
zu bleiben,
was er ist
, sobald der individuelle
wille in seiner selbstbezogenheit durch
die forderung des sittengesetzes herausgefordert wird, eine
gegentendenz zu bleiben  in seinem
vorherigen Zustand entsteht in ihm eine Art Abwehr- oder
definierte Reaktion, die
zu seiner Verdunkelung führt
Seine Reaktion der Verdunkelung ist nur die
positive Seite des Bösen,
da es eine willentliche Reflexion
und alle Gründe beinhaltet, weil
wir diese Aktivität rechtfertigen
, und hier ist die Schlussfolgerung, dass
beide tatsächlich argumentieren können, dass unmoralische
Handlungen auch nicht zurückverfolgt werden können  der
bloßen Heteronomie, sei es die Notwendigkeit der
Natur oder der Notwendigkeit des Sittengesetzes,
noch einer Art Indifferentismus,
eher unmoralisches Handeln, kann
unserer individuellen Freiheit und Rationalität eine
Rationalität unterstellt werden, die weder mit der
reinen praktischen Vernunft identisch ist noch als ihr entgegengesetzt
ist  Eine Art böse Vernunft,
die erste würde auf verständlichen
Fatalismus hinauslaufen, die letztere würde uns zu einem
teuflischen Fleischwesen machen, wie [ __ ] und
Sieger argumentieren,
da Canton davon spricht, dass Vernunft
und Wille tief miteinander verflochten sind, sind wir
in gewisser Weise nicht an die Normativität der Vernunft gebunden
das macht die Abweichung
davon unmöglich, vielmehr können wir
unsere Vernunftfähigkeit gegen seine moralische
Forderung einsetzen, wenn nicht sogar schlimm  Die unmittelbar und unmittelbar
so zumindest indirekt und verschleierend
verschleiernde Vernunft ist also nichts
Irrationales
, sondern eine innere Tendenz
eben jener Vernunft, die wesentlich zu
uns gehört, also zu solch endlichen vernünftigen Wesen gehört,
wie wir Menschen es sind.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit,
ja, danke  für den sehr interessanten
Vortrag dachte ich an das großartige
Werk für Metaphysik der Moral,
wo wir diese Klassifizierung
zwischen verschiedenen Arten von Imperativen haben,
und ich dachte, ist das nicht,
wo wir eine rationale Grundlage finden können,
auf der wir
irgendeine Art aufbauen können?  von Arten von Imperativen,
die vielleicht nicht moralisch gut, aber
immer noch gut sind.
Glauben Sie also nicht, dass es ein Einkommen gibt,
diese Möglichkeit
,
das Gute aktiv zu wollen, was moralisch nicht gut ist, beispielsweise
durch hypothetische Imperative,
was bedeutet, etwas als Mittel
zu einem anderen Zweck zu wollen  aber nicht als ein an sich
und damit nicht dem sittlichen
Gesetz entsprechendes
also der Unterschied zwischen dem
kategorischen Impe  rative und die
hypothetische Universität, wenn
genau diese Unterscheidung ein rationaler
Grund wäre, aktiv
ein Gut zu wählen, das moralisch nicht gut ist,
und dieser Sinn kann böse sein.
Vielen Dank, das ist eine gute
Frage.
Ich habe auch darüber nachgedacht, aber ich würde
argumentieren, dass ähm  Hypothetische Imperative
sind nicht der beste
Weg, um zu erklären, wie wir frei und
zurechnungsfähig zu
unmoralischem Handeln kommen, denn der letzte
Grund hypothetischer Imperative wäre
in gewisser Weise Sensibilität, also in individuellen
Zielen, die zu
der Art und Weise gehören, wie wir Dinge genießen
und i  Ich denke, es ist in gewisser Weise tiefer, dass
der Grund dafür, gegen das moralische
Gesetz zu handeln, nicht nur etwas Empirisches ist
, das ich erreichen möchte,
sondern es ist die eigentliche Struktur
unserer individuellen Vernunft,
nämlich die Tendenz,
dialektisch zu werden,
also würde ich es tun  würde argumentieren, dass hypothetische
Imperative zu nah an
der Naturnotwendigkeit oder zu nah an
empirischen
Umständen sind, die ähm,
das ähm, eine Art Heteron bedeutet
Aber ich denke, dass wir uns
unmoralische Handlungen auf eine stärkere Weise vorstellen können
, die mit
unserer Natur der Rationalität zu tun hat, nämlich
dialektische
Rationalität, aber es ist eine interessante
Möglichkeit,
aber ich habe darüber nachgedacht, aber ich würde sagen, wir müssen
etwas zwischen
dem Kategorischen sein  Imperative und
hypothetische Agenten und dies
wäre ein dialektischer Grund in Bezug auf die
Rationalisierung, wie ich es verstehe.
Danke,
äh, danke,
äh, es gibt noch eine Frage von äh,
Martin
Ich
möchte nur sagen, dass der Grund, warum ich mich nicht
mit einem Nashorn-Dilemma befasse, darin besteht, dass ich
es zu schwierig finde, ähm, und
deshalb finde ich es großartig, dass Sie
diesen Kopf anpacken, es ist nur etwas
, von dem ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich es wahrscheinlich könnte.  Ich
konnte dieses Problem überhaupt nicht lösen,
weil es so tief und schwierig ist. Ähm,
okay, also hier sind, wenn ich zwei Fragen gestellt habe,
aber ich kann auch, wenn es nur eine Frage
pro Person ist, einfach fragen  ab und zu eine
andere Frage später, also die erste
, die sich speziell auf
Ihr Gespräch bezieht, ähm, waren Sie Sie haben manchmal gesagt,
dass ähm Rationalisierung Gründe schafft,
gegen das moralische Gesetz zu handeln oder so etwas.
Ich meine, ich habe mich gefragt
, ob Sie das sagen wollten
Wollten Sie sagen, dass es tatsächlich
Gründe schafft oder so etwas wie
scheinbare Gründe, scheinbare Gründe,
also habe ich mich meiner Meinung nach richtig entschieden,
ähm, Sie schaffen nicht wirklich
Gründe, das moralische Gesetz zu verletzen,
sondern Sie denken, dass Sie es tun,
ähm, und ich war es  Ich frage mich, ob wir uns darüber nicht einig sind,
ob dies tatsächlich in irgendeiner Weise
stichhaltige Gründe sind, um das moralische Gesetz zu verletzen,
das Sie aus der
Rationalisierung erhalten, oder
ist es der Fall, dass sie Gründe zu sein scheinen,
aber sie sind überhaupt keine Gründe,
denke ich Sie  könnte für beide Positionen argumentieren,
obwohl ich meine Position offensichtlich bevorzuge,
aber ich bin interessiert, also wenn wir
rationalisieren, vielleicht wirklich gut rationalisieren,
ähm, Sie wissen, wir haben diese wirklich
plausible
Erklärung, dass w  Wir können angeben, warum
wir tun dürfen, was
wir tun. Bekommen wir tatsächliche Gründe oder
vielleicht sogar tatsächliche Entschuldigungen für das, was wir
tun?
Vielen Dank. Ich
interpretiere Gründe immer als Gründe für Handlungen,
also in einem Begriff  In Bezug auf eine Motivationskraft
und aus dieser Perspektive würde ich sagen,
dass selbst scheinbare Gründe
Gründe sind, die keine guten Gründe sind,
aber es gibt Gründe, ich meine,
schließlich führen sie mich zu dieser Aktion, also haben
sie diese Funktion, mich zu motivieren, ähm
und ich  würde so sagen mein arg meine
antwort wäre sogar triefende gründe sind
gründe
für mein handeln grund für
unmoralisches handeln
und ich würde nicht zwischen
gründen und scheinbaren gründen unterscheiden
ich würde argumentieren das sind unmoralische gründe
vielleicht
gründe die
im einklang mit dem sittengesetz stehen oder
dagegen sind aber trotzdem gibt es
gründe die mich zu mehr
aktion motivieren und es sind gründe weil sie
mit meiner individuellen freiheit zu tun haben
ähm die
ihnen so gehören  sind von Natur aus
mit
Individualität und Freiheit verbunden,
wenn auch nicht mit Autonomie im engeren
Sinne, denn dann müssten wir
mehr Gründe haben, ja, aber es ist
eine wichtige Frage, aber meine Antwort
wäre, dass sie Gründe sind,
okay, aber vielleicht wir  geh zu eleanor und
dann komme ich zurück zu dir martin für deine
zweite
frage äh eleanor
okay erstmal vielen dank
für dieses interessante papier also ich habe zwei
fragen
ähm beide für kans und victor
und diese zwei fragen
[musik]
gutsind
sie  betreffen die begriffe bzw. in erster
linie die grenzen unserer vernunft
und ähm den begriff der verantwortung also in
erster linie die grenzen der vernunft
also habe ich nach dem hören deines
vortrags den eindruck, dass
nach kant und victor
unsere praktische vernunft so begrenzt ist
wir neigen zu
illusionen und ähm
und einer obskuren und unbestimmten
unbestimmten art, über ähm moral nachzudenken,
also ist meine erste frage nach
khans und victor
d  o wir haben wirklich die fähigkeit
, die moralische forderung kennenzulernen
, nach der wir handeln sollten
, um zu entscheiden, oh, um später zu denken,
okay, wir werden,
wir werden dagegen vorgehen,
also das lied ja,
meine erste frage  Ist gut, haben wir
dieses Wissen überhaupt
? Ja,
meine zweite Frage ist,
ob unsere unmoralischen Handlungen
als Illusion oder Verschleierung des
moralischen Gesetzes erklärt
werden können, inwieweit können wir dann sagen, dass wir
für unsere eigenen
unmoralischen Handlungen verantwortlich sind
Inwieweit können wir sagen, dass es
wirklich
unsere Fehler sind,
ähm
ja
danke vielen Dank für Ihre wichtigen
Fragen,
also die erste Frage, die ich argumentieren würde, dass der
Grund
an sich
eine Höhe ist, wie ich sagte,
aus diesem Grund hochproblematisch,
schrieb [ __ ]  die kritik der reinen vernunft,
weil die reine vernunft immer danach
strebt, die grenze des wissens zu überschreiten,
und ich würde argumentieren, dass sogar die praktische
vernunft höchst problematisch ist,
weil sie mit der natürlichen dialektik zu tun hat,
also wou  Ich argumentiere, dass Vernunft immer
anfällig für Illusionen ist, sei es theoretische
Vernunft oder praktische Vernunft
und zumindest in Bezug auf
rein theoretische und rein praktische
Vernunft in Bezug auf Menschen oder
einzelne endliche Wesen, so dass es eine Spannung gibt, von der
man immer denkt, dass reine
Vernunft etwas ist  gehört zu einem
unendlichen subjekt, aber wir müssen
diesen speziellen fall der reinen vernunft, der rein
praktischen oder rein theoretischen vernunft
, die zu einem endlichen subjekt gehört, diskutieren, und ich
finde, es gibt eine spannung und einen spalt, den ich
bisher nicht lösen konnte, aber wir sollten dies
immer berücksichtigen  weil es eine
andere Vorstellung von reiner Vernunft oder
reiner praktischer Vernunft gibt, die
nicht zu einem endlichen Subjekt gehört, sondern zu einer
vielleicht universellen Annahme, und die
universelle Universalität des moralischen Gesetzes
suggeriert ein solches universelles Wesen auf eine Weise
, die nicht endlich ist, also müssen wir uns das
vorstellen  von
endlichen Wesen
in
Koordination in Kooperation in
Verbindung mit reiner praktischer und
theoretischer Vernunft
und dadurch re  Beziehung besteht
immer die Tendenz,
die Grenzen zu überschreiten, sei es in
theoretischer Hinsicht eine reine Vernunft,
die mit ihren Ideen die Grenzen des Wissens überschreitet,
aber auch in praktischer
Hinsicht die Überschreitung der
Grenzen des moralischen Gesetzes, nämlich im Sinne der
Rationalisierung  So wie ich es ausdrücke
und
die zweite Frage würde ich argumentieren, dass
ähm,
ich meine in Kant ist die Tatsache der Vernunft, also
wird das moralische Gesetz in bestimmten Fällen ziemlich offensichtlich,
aber ähm, ich würde argumentieren,
dass
[ __ ] dieser Tatsache der Vernunft ziemlich kritisch gegenübersteht,
weil  er redet immer von
diesen gegengewichten, diese
arten
von verschleiern, er
spricht auch von einer
hinderung der reinen praktischen vernunft er redet von
verschiedenen arten neben
rationalisierungen von selbstüberheblichkeit und so weiter
[ __ ] ist sich dessen durchaus bewusst
Das Moralgesetz wird
uns nicht einfach gegeben, also müssen wir für
diese Präsenz arbeiten, also
ist es eine Errungenschaft, das Moralgesetz klar vor Augen zu haben,
und ich würde es nicht sagen.  Es ist nicht der
Anfang, es ist sozusagen nicht umsonst,
wir müssen hart dafür arbeiten und wir müssen
gegen bestimmte Tendenzen
in uns arbeiten, die uns noch zugeschrieben werden können,
nämlich Rationalisierung von Selbstdünkel,
Selbstliebe und so weiter und so weiter
mit unserer endlichkeit in kombination mit
rein praktischer und theoretischer vernunft zu tun,
aber es ist eine wichtige frage und dies
ist nicht meine endgültige antwort darauf. ich
denke noch darüber nach ja
danke danke trottel und wir gehen zurück zu
martin für seine  Zweite äh Frage,
großartig, danke, ähm, das ist eine Sache, die
ich mich eigentlich nur über mich selbst frage,
und ich frage mich, ob Sie etwas
zu sagen haben, was mir auffällt
, dass Kant die Möglichkeit nicht zu erwägen scheint
Jemand
könnte es bereuen, rational zu rationalisieren, die
rationalen Fähigkeiten zu missbrauchen, und es trotzdem richtig machen,
nur weil
er kein Glück hat, oder manchmal, und das
festzustellen, würde ein bisschen Streit erfordern,
manchmal könnte jemand
tatsächlich sein
ähm
missverstehen
ihre Pflichten und denken, dass sie mehr schulden,
als sie tatsächlich tun,
obwohl Khan dem wahrscheinlich nicht zustimmen würde
, aber es scheint mir, dass
dies der Fall sein kann, und dann, wenn Sie
rationalisieren, um Ihre Selbstliebe gegen das zu verteidigen,
was Sie wahrnehmen
um eine pflicht zu sein, könntest du am ende
verstehen, was du eigentlich
deine pflicht ist weißt du ich habe
mich nur gefragt ob ähm ob das nach
deiner vorstellung möglich ist oder ob du
zustimmen würdest, dass rationalisieren ich glaube du
hast es ausführlich beschrieben  als
negativ und als Missbrauch der Vernunft und
etwas,
das unmoralische Handlungen erklärt, aber unmöglich
erklären kann, wie wir es tatsächlich richtig machen könnten,
ähm, und ich denke, das hängt ein bisschen
mit Ihrem Punkt zusammen, wo Sie sagten,
dass ähm Gründe für
Sie gerecht sind  Motivationsgründe
ähm, weil Sie denken könnten, wenn
Sie wirklich starke Motivationsgründe
haben, wäre das zumindest
eine Entschuldigung für etwas Richtiges, vielleicht
keine Rechtfertigung für ws  Das tun Sie, aber
wenn wir einen Agenten beurteilen, muss es
sicher etwas bedeuten, dass seine
Motivation und seine Gründe superstark waren,
im Gegensatz zu jemandem,
der etwas Unmoralisches tut, wo er
eher schwache, sogar subjektive Motivationsgründe
hat,
also habe ich mich gefragt, was Sie
davon halten  ist auch eine wichtige Frage, also
[ __ ], ich denke, in seiner Religion
unterscheidet zwischen verschiedenen Arten von
Vernunft, wenn ich mich nicht irre, spricht er von
subjektiver und objektiver Vernunft,
wie in seiner Religion, ich denke, es ist in einer
Fußnote,
also gibt es diese Passage im
Hintergrund  zwischen objektiven und
subjektiven Gründen, also ist immer die
Frage, ob subjektive Gründe
überhaupt
nicht frei sind, ob sie zu unserer Freiheit beitragen, und ich
fand immer, selbst wenn wir
zwischen objektiven und subjektiven Gründen unterscheiden,
müssen beide Gründe unsere Freiheit erklären,
also
könnten Sie vielleicht wiederholen  Ihre Frage
, so würde ich mich auf diese
Passage beziehen und diese Unterscheidung
zwischen subjektiv und objektiv machen  Gründe
, die zu Ihrer Frage beitragen könnten,
aber vielleicht habe ich es nicht genau verstanden,
könnten Sie es wiederholen, und wenn ich es nicht
vollständig beantwortet habe,
könnten Sie es vielleicht
wiederholen
äh, meine
Hauptfrage war, ob ich
etwas rationalisieren und es trotzdem
richtig machen kann, weißt du, kann ich es verwenden
und eine tatsächliche Rechtfertigung dafür finden,
also habe ich diese Vorgehensweise, die ich im
Grunde genommen mache, ich werde es
richtig machen und dann  Ich fange an, eine
Rechtfertigung dafür zu konstruieren, und ich denke
, das ist ein paradigmatischer Fall von Rationalisierung,
bei dem wir uns
zuerst auf eine Vorgehensweise festlegen und dann
versuchen,
Sie wissen, normativ gültiges
Zeug zu finden, das es uns im Grunde ermöglichen würde,
unsere Handlungen vor uns selbst zu rechtfertigen
aber wir könnten es schaffen,
wir könnten wirklich gute Gründe
dafür finden, obwohl
wir unsere Meinung nicht ändern würden, wenn wir es nicht getan hätten
, da scheint etwas
mangelhaft zu sein, aber
wir könnten es trotzdem tun  Ich verstehe es in dem Sinne,
dass wir
uns auf das Richtige einigen, okay, also
wäre das ein moralischer Kontext, um es
richtig zu machen, oder wäre das ein instrumenteller
Kontext, nein, ich
denke also, dass Rationalisierung sich
speziell auf moralische Fälle bezieht,
aber okay  Ich weiß, Sie sind anderer Meinung. Eines der
interessanten Dinge an Ihrer Arbeit ist, dass
Sie sie auch auf ähm theoretische
Fragen ausdehnen. Ja, okay,
ich meine, ich würde zustimmen, dass
die Art und Weise, wie ich sie verwende, rationalisieren, äh, auch
auf die
Moral beschränkt ist
äh Umstände, also ist die Frage
interessant ähm können wir durch Rationalisierung
moralisch werden ist das die
Frage moralisch sein durch Rationalisierung
ähm können wir durch Rationalisierung etwas lernen
ja sicher lernen ich bin mir
sicher lerne sicher aber ich bin mir nicht
sicher  wenn es
etwas wirklich Moralisches ist, zu dem
wir durch Rationalisierung gelangen, denke ich, dass
Rationalisierung immer die
Tendenz hat,
die eigene Individualität gegen die
Universalität des moralischen Gesetzes zu betonen  Ich denke,
es ist dieser Konflikt und wenn wir in diesen Konflikt geraten und uns
nur auf unsere Individualität konzentrieren, indem
ich rationalisiere, meine ich, es gibt einen anderen
Punkt,
den
die Leute
diskutieren könnten, ist, nur
über Einzelpersonen zu rationalisieren oder kann es auch
über Kollektive gehen? Ja, das haben die
Organisatoren gefragt  mir diese Frage,
aber ich würde sagen, Rationalisierung ist
in moralischer Hinsicht etwas von Natur aus
problematisch. Moralisch
problematisch  kompatibel mit instrumentalem
Denken, weil es so ist,
soweit ich gefragt habe, es hat in gewisser Weise
etwas, das hypothetischen Imperativen nahe kommt,
aber ich würde nicht behaupten, dass es damit identisch ist
, ich würde mich voneinander unterscheiden,
danke,
und dann gibt es noch eine Frage  von paul
reichel,
also vielen dank für das gespräch, also denke ich,
dass diese frage vielleicht in eine
ähnliche richtung geht,
also ja, also der reinhold  Dilemma Ich denke auch
, dass es ein enorm
kompliziertes
Problem ist, so sehr, dass ich nicht
genau verstand, wie
Ihr Konto es Kant ermöglichen würde, darauf zu
antworten, also legen Sie äh fikta vorerst beiseite,
ähm, so ausdrücklich glaube ich, dass ich es nicht getan habe
Verstehen Sie, es scheint zwei Arten von Vorstellungen von Vernunft oder Rationalität zu geben, eine ist die gewichtige kantische oder
es gibt einen direkten Weg von dieser zu
Freiheit und
Moral usw. usw.
und ich denke, das Problem
mit dieser ist, dass sie so gewichtig ist oder
starkes Recht, das ist das, was man nicht
von der Freiheit trennen kann
, das ist das Reinhold-Problem, ähm, aber dann
gibt es noch dieses andere von
diesem deflationäreren Recht, du hast
Davidson erwähnt, also diese Art von
mehr Geschäft des Gebens und Fragens nach
Gründen, ähm, aber das  Eins, es
gibt keinen direkten Weg zur Freiheit oder und
Moral, mit diesem einen Recht könntest
du ein Determinist sein und ähm
und und trotzdem weißt du, dass du dich in diesem
Geschäft des Gebens und Fragens von
Gründen beteiligst  Bei einem scheint es nicht so zu sein, als wäre
es in diesem Problem gefangen, ähm,
in einer Weise, wie es beim ersten der Fall ist
stützen Sie sich auf diese erste
gewichtige kantianische Vorstellung von
praktischer Vernunft oder Rationalität in diesem
starken Sinne.
Vielen Dank, dies betrifft die
Vorstellung von
Vernunft und [ __ ], was ein wirklich
großes Thema ist,
aber ich stimme zu, also versuche ich zu argumentieren, dass wir
zwischen ihnen unterscheiden müssen  Eine Vorstellung von
reiner Vernunft, die
nicht mit Individualität verbunden ist,
und eine Vorstellung von reiner Vernunft, die
mit Individualität verbunden ist, und ich denke,
es gibt eine,
macht diese Unterscheidung nicht sehr klar,
aber ich denke, wir müssen
zwischen diesen beiden Arten von reiner Vernunft unterscheiden
in cunt um
laura papisch hat sie in ihrem buch über
selbsttäuschung an einer passage
auf diese konzeption der reinen
vernunft hingewiesen, die immer noch dem einzelnen gehört, was
ich sehr hilfreich fand, aber
nur in einer fußnote
Ich denke auch, dass wir
etwas zwischen der reinen allgemeinen
Vernunft haben müssen, die nicht mit endlichen
Subjekten verbunden ist, wie wir es sind, und einer Vorstellung von
Vernunft, die mehr mit
hypothetischer instrumenteller Vernunft zusammenhängt, also was
ich
Rationalitäten
oder Rationalität der
rationalen
Rationalisierung finde  Diese
endliche reine Vernunft, die ich als
endliche reine Vernunft und endliche reine
Vernunft bezeichnen
würde, hätte
ähm einige
Merkmale
ähm in Bezug auf ähm Davidson Davidsons
Rationalitätskonzept, das ich
nicht
als
identisch mit hypothetischer Vernunft begreifen würde. Ich denke,
Davidson hat ein sehr breites Konzept  von
Rationalität ist nicht nur mit Moral verbunden,
wie Sie gesagt haben,
sondern es ist eine Art von Rationalität, die
wir immer noch mit unserer individuellen
Freiheit verbinden können
Ihre Handlungen und diese Darstellung der
Irrationalität wären nicht nur
instrumentelle Vernunft,
weil es keine braucht
Sensibilität oder ähnliches
involviert sein, kann es nur um mein
Verhältnis zum moralischen Gesetz gehen und diese
Art von Rationalität
muss von der allgemeinen nicht endlichen
reinen Vernunft unterschieden werden, und wie gesagt,
es gibt einige
, die man immer
verspannen kann, oder einige, die
Dinge
können  Es gibt keine einheitliche Vorstellung von reiner
Vernunft, und ich denke, das ist nicht wahr.
Manchmal spricht [ __ ] von
gewöhnlicher Vernunft
und nicht von rein praktischer Vernunft, und diese
gemeinsame Vernunft
ist keine instrumentelle Vernunft, also denke ich,
dass wir zwischen diesen
verschiedenen Arten von Vernunft unterscheiden müssen  dann beziehen Sie
diese Arten von Vernunft auf diese spezifischen
moralischen Probleme wie
Unmoral, Freiheit, unmoralisch zu handeln und
so weiter, aber ich würde, ich würde Ihnen zustimmen,
es ist nicht
ganz klar,
uh Khans Auffassung von Vernunft, und wir
müssen wirklich verschiedene
Arten von Zukunft unterscheiden,
danke
ähm karen hat vielleicht die letzte frage
okay äh ja danke für dieses interessante
äh papier und die diskussion
also ich habe eine kleine frage die vielleicht ist
im Zusammenhang mit Ihrem Dialog mit äh Martin
äh über den Begriff van nuyvdon
und ähm, also bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob
die Übersetzung
als rationalisierend
a
die Hauptbedeutung von Fernando erfasst,
weil ich denke, äh York, dass
Sie
die negative um Konnotation von betonen  feminin
ja so
also wenn du wenn du in frankreich beschäftigt
bist kannst du äh entschuldigungen finden oder oder
du
kannst dir
gründe für dein verhalten einfallen
aber es ist
es ist immer äh etwas was
ich negativ finde ja da ist das denke
ich das  Der negative Aspekt verschwindet aus der
Rationalisierung
und das ist vielleicht
der Grund, warum Martin äh
Ihnen diese Frage gestellt hat.
Können
wir
durch den Prozess der
Rationalisierung zu einer gewissen Einsicht in unsere Pflicht kommen
und Sie zögern, dies zu
akzeptieren, und ich war
ich war  Ich denke, dass dies vielleicht
durch diese
unterschiedlichen Konnotationen des deutschen
Begriffs und der äh englischen Übersetzung verursacht wird.
Vielen Dank, also gibt es eine
Diskussion darüber, wie man ein
Phäno setzt  lphthalein auf englisch, also
sagen manche leute, es sei vernünftig, manche
sagen,
es sei
rationalisierend.
ähm, nehmen wir das deutsche
fenunten  zu rationalisieren und
es
gibt rationalisierer, die
wirklich gute rationalisierer sind, und es gibt
rationalisierer, die überhaupt keine
guten rationalisierer sind, also kann man das
in gewisser weise qualitativ beurteilen,
aber am ende würde ich das
richtig sagen  Meiner Meinung nach auch vom deutschen
Wort für Mittag
[Musik]
, es ist etwas, das
mit
rationaler Ausstattung, rationalen Fähigkeiten zu tun hat,
aber es ist nicht
die
Art und Weise, wie es verwendet werden soll,
also ist es immer auf eine Art und Weise,
ähm
nicht
in  die Richtung des Realen oder die
Richtung, in die es gehen sollte, also gibt es
ein Normatives als eine Art negativer
Normativität,
äh, eine Einschränkung, die mit
Rationalisierung verbunden ist, obwohl es darin ist  eine seltene
fähigkeit, deshalb ist das wichtig ich
möchte betonen es ist kein unvermögen
kann manchmal von unvermögen sprechen
ich würde immer sagen es ist ein
rationalisationsvermögen und hat daher eine
positive bedeutung aber am ende
mit bezug auf die moral  gesetz
und diese absolute forderung ist eine
möglichkeit, diese absolute forderung zu verschleiern oder zu umgehen,
indem sie mit
äußerst intelligenten
mitteln sicher ist
danke inzwischen
hat im chat eine diskussion über äh
alternativen begonnen ja sophisterei ich fand
das gut gut manchmal nicht gebrauchen  Ein
Oberflächenbaum und Sofisten sind intelligente
Menschen,
und am Ende
verfehlen sie
das moralische Gesetz und sind sich bewusst, aber es ist
eine wichtige Diskussion